SPECIAL HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. WE DO NOT
YET HAVE A QUORUM BUT WE WILL.
START AS A SUB COMMITTEE WE HAVE
. ONE BILL BEFORE US TODAY AND
THAT IS AB. TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE. BY MEMBERS WICKS AND
GRAYSON. SO COUPLE OF TECHNICAL
ISSUES AS WE GET STARTED SO
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE DESK
AND WHILE THERE ARE NO. MANDATES
ABOUT MASKS AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING WE DO KNOW THAT CODE
NINETEEN HAS NOT GONE AWAY WE
ASK FOLKS TO BE. RESPECTFUL OF
THAT AND WE SHOULD ALL GO ABOUT
OUR LIVES LITTLE BIT MORE
CAREFULLY THAN WE HAD BEFORE IN
ORDER TO NOT SPREAD THE DISEASE
. WE DO HAVE TWO DIFFERENT TYPES
OF TESTIMONY AVAILABLE WITH US
WHO ARE AVAILABLE TODAY
CERTAINLY WELCOME TO BE HERE IN
THE HEARING ROOM AND GIVE
TESTIMONY. WHEN WE GET TO PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IF THERE ARE WITNESS
SPEAKERS AND I DON'T HAVE ANY
LISTED SO- BUT WITH THE SPEAKERS
ARE WELCOME TO COME UP TO THE
TABLES HERE OTHERWISE USE THE
MICROPHONE THAT IS. IN THE
MIDDLE OF CHAMBERS ALTHOUGH WE
DO ASK THAT. ANYONE TESTIFYING
ALLOW THE SERGEANTS TO HANDLE
THE MICROPHONE IN THE KNOWING TO
TOUCH THE MICROPHONE WE
APPRECIATE THAT. IS ALSO
AVAILABLE TO CALL IN AND THE
TOLL FREE NUMBER WHICH SHOULD BE
ON YOUR SCREEN RIGHT NOW IS.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AGAIN
THAT'S EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX
NINE TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN.
WITH THE PUBLIC ACCESS CODE OF
ONE THREE ONE FIVE FOUR FOUR
FOUR AGAIN THAT'S ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR FOUR FOUR. WE DO HAVE
THE ONE BILL AND WE WILL
ESTABLISH QUORUM ONCE WE GET A
QUORUM. SO MR GRAYSON IS WORKS.
WELCOME FLOOR'S YOURS. SB YOU GO
FIRST. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS AS THEY
ARRIVE THANKS TO THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE WORK THAT HAS BEEN DONE
ON THIS BILL AND I WILL ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE WHICH
WILL EXTEND EVICTION PROTECTIONS
FOR TENANTS WHO HAVE FILED FOR
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE BY
THE END OF THIS MONTH. SINCE THE
RENT RELIEF PROGRAM LAUNCHED ONE
YEAR AGO CALIFORNIANS HAVE A
CALIFORNIA HAS LED THE NATION IN
DELIVERING ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
MOST IN NEED AND AT RISK OF
LOSING THEIR HOUSING THE STATE
PROGRAM HAS DELIVERED OVER TWO
POINT FOUR SIX BILLION IN DIRECT
ASSISTANCE TO DATE HELPING MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN
THOUSAND LOW INCOME HOUSEHOLDS
PAY OFF RENTAL DEBT AND AVOID
EVICTION. ONE IN THREE PAYMENTS
NATIONALLY HAVE BEEN MADE IN
CALIFORNIA TO TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS IN NEED BUT IT IS
TAKING LONGER THAN EXPECTED FOR
THE STATE TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS FOR COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
THOUSANDS CONTINUE TO WAIT FOR
RELIEF WHILE THEIR APPLICATIONS
TEND. IT WOULD BE CRUEL IT WOULD
BE WASTEFUL AND UNFAIR TO
SUBJECT CALIFORNIANS TO
EVICTIONS OR THE LOSS OF RENTAL
INCOME ESPECIALLY NOW WHEN THEY
HAVE DONE EVERYTHING THAT HAS
BEEN ASKED OF THEM AND
DISTRIBUTION OF THEIR INCOME AT
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE IS
EMINENT WE ARE NOT GOING TO
ALLOW CALIFORNIANS TO SUFFER TO
LOSE THEIR HOMES OR EVEN THEIR
INCOME BECAUSE OF APPLICATION
PROCESSING TIMES. AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE IS GOING TO HELP US
TAKE CARE OF THE THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS TENANTS AND
LANDLORDS ALIKE WHO APPLIED TO
COVERT NINETEEN EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND STILL HAVE THEIR
APPLICATIONS PENDING THIS WILL
pLET US MACHTE MAXIMIZE EVERY
LAST EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
DOLLAR TO KEEP PEOPLE HOUSED
EVEN AS THE PROGRAM COMES TO AN
END. I DO HAVE. THANKS WILL.
MISS WORK THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS STAFF. WE HONOR THAT
CALIFORNIA WAS ALREADY FACING A
HOUSING CRISIS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC STARTED YEARS OF
SKYROCKETING RENTS AND HOME
PRICES MEANT THAT SAFE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WAS OUT OF
REACH FOR FAR TOO MANY FAMILIES
AND WHEN COVERED HAD IT DIDN'T
AFFECT US ALL EQUALLY. JOB
LOSSES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED OUR MOST ECONOMICALLY
VULNERABLE RENTERS PARTICULARLY
IN OUR BROWN A BLACK
COMMUNITIES. IN RESPONSE THE
STATE TOOK MUCH NEEDED ACTION
AND I WAS A PROUD CO AUTHOR OF
AB THREE ZERO EIGHT EIGHT. THIS
THIS BILL THE BODY AT THE- THE
BILL THIS BODY PASSED IN AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY TO ESTABLISH
EVICTION PROTECTIONS THAT ENSURE
NO RENTERS LOST THEIR HOMES JUST
BECAUSE THEY WERE UNABLE. TO PAY
RENTS DURING THE PANDEMIC. BUT
FOR MANY TENANTS WHO ARE ALREADY
LIVING PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK
MONTHS OF MISTRUST PAYMENTS
BEGIN TO ADD UP AND RENTAL
PROPERTY OWNERS LIKE WHY
STRUGGLE TO COVER THEIR
EXPENSES. OVER TIME WE'VE LIFTED
PORTIONS OF THE STATE'S EVICTION
PROTECTIONS AND SHIFTED OUR
FOCUS TO DISTRIBUTING OVER FIVE
POINT TWO BILLION RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDS TO COVER MISSED
RENT PAYMENTS FOR LOW INCOME
TENANT HOUSEHOLDS. HOWEVER THE
WORK IS NOT DONE. AS WE SPEAK
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
APPLICATIONS FOR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE ARE STILL UNDER
REVIEW. BUT THE PROTECTIONS THAT
POSITIVE ACTIONS EVICT EVICTION
CASES FOR THOSE TENANTS WILL
EXPIRE THIS WEEK IF WE DO NOT
ACT ON THIS BILL. UNDER AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE TENDED
TO APPLIED TO RENTAL ASSISTANCE
BY MARCH THIRTY FIRST WILL
CONTINUE TO RECEIVE PROTECTIONS
THROUGH JUNE OF THIS YEAR.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL PROVIDES
UNIFORM STATEWIDE PROTECTIONS
UNTIL JULY FIRST. WE KNOW THIS
BILL ISN'T PERFECT BUT ONE THING
IS CERTAIN. WITHOUT THIS
LEGISLATION TENANTS RISK BEING
EVICTED DESPITE THE FACT THAT
THEY'VE APPLIED FOR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE FUNDS. THAT WILL MAKE
THEIR LANDLORDS HOLE ONCE THE
APPLICATION IS PROCESS AND
APPROVED. COLLEAGUES WE SIMPLY
CANNOT SIT BACK AND WATCH THIS
HAPPEN AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS IMPORTANT BILL. THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW GO TO PROPONENTS
AGAIN I HAVE NEITHER SUPPORTERS
NOR. OPPONENTS LISTED BUT IS
THERE ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK. IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MISTER
CHAIRMAN DEBRA CARLTON THE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT ASSOCIATION
WERE THE LARGEST RENTAL
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION IN THE
NATION BUT I WILL WANT TO MAKE
CLEAR THAT MOST OF OUR MEMBERS%
ARE SMALL MOM AND POP OWNERS WE
BELIEVE THIS IS A NARROW
APPROACH WE APPRECIATE THE FACT
IT'S A NARROW APPROACH ONLY
PROTECTING OWNES. AND TENANTS
WHO APPLIED BEFORE MARCH THIRTY
FIRST AND THE CONSISTENCY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT WE CAN'T
HAVE DIFFERENT ALL LOCAL
ORDINANCES THROUGHOUT THE STATE
SO WE APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT
YOU'VE TAKEN A BALANCED APPROACH
HERE AND WE WOULD THAT WOULD WE
WOULD WE RESPECT THAT SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE
BEFORE WE GO TO THE TELEPHONES
IN SUPPORT I WOULD LIKE TO.
ESTABLISH A QUORUM PLEASE AND I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT WE HAVE
TO MEMBERS WITH US TODAY MR.
pBENNETT AND MR BLOOM WELCOME.
STONE CUNNINGHAM DAVIES. HOLDEN
KALRA KILEY MAIENSCHEIN REYES
BLOOM SENATE. RIGHT THANK YOU SO
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM. OUR I'M A
TWEENER. THIRTY ALL RIGHT GO
HEAD SB CONLEY WITH THE L. A.
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
WE DO NOT CURRENTLY HAVE A
POSITION WHEN I THINK AUTHORS
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD
VERY BRIEFLY TO- EXTEND THE
CERTAIN PROTECTIONS THAT ARE IN
THERE L. A. COUNTY DID IN
JANUARY PASSED A PRETTY
COMPREHENSIVE- RENTER
PROTECTIONS- ORDINANCE THAT
EXTENDS TO THE DECEMBER IT'S A
VERY THOUGHTFUL A PHASED OUT
PROCESS THAT OFFERS A LOT MORE
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE CONSIDERED
IN THIS BILL I WE'RE PRETTY
WORRIED ABOUT THE LOCAL
PREEMPTION THAT WILL BE GOING
INTO PLACE AND IT WOULD BE
REMISS TO NOT MENTION THAT WE
WOULD. APPRECIATE THE- COMMITTEE
CONSIDERING GETTING RID OF THE
PREEMPTION IN THE BILL. THANK
YOU. ALL RIGHT OPERATOR WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONES FOR ANYONE
WHO'D LIKE TO INDICATE SUPPORT.
FOR THIS BILL IF YOU COULD. AN
ALLIANCE FOR AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE AT THIS POINT WE'LL
TAKE THOSE WHO JUST NAME
AFFILIATION AND SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO MAKE A COMMENT YOU CAN PRESS.
ONE AND THEN ZERO POINT YOUR
TOUCH TONE PHONE YOU MAY USE
THESE. GLAZER AT RIGHT ONE AND
TWO MAKE IT AFTER HOME IT COMES
FROM THE LINE IN PLEASE DON'T
HEAD. IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE THANK YOU THANK
YOU. OUR NEXT LINE IS TWELVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BRENT MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION AND ITS HOUSING IS A
HUMAN RIGHT DIVISION IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL IF AMENDED TO
EXCLUDE THE LOCAL PREEMPTION
THANK YOU. NEXT IN QUEUE IS
LYING TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS TINA REGARDS
WITH WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE DO NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL WE
ARE NEUTRAL- BECAUSE THAT IS
THAT TEN THOUSAND THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE WITH- BY NOT ALLOWING
THEM TO APPLY TO THE PROGRAM
PACKED MARCH THIRTY. THANK YOU.
NEXT COMMENT COMES FROM THE LINE
CHECKS PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE SHARON CONSULTANT
WITH THE RUNNING PUBLIC POLICY
GROUP ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
MOUNTAIN VIEW IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. AND THE LAST ONE IN QUEUE
AT THIS TIME THIS LINE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MICHAEL RAT
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND SUPPORT THANKYOU.
THERE'S CURRENTLY NOBODY ELSE
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT THANK YOU
OPERATOR WILL NOW MOVE TO
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONEHERE
IN THE CHAMBERS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRED
MEMBERS KATE ALLEN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION AND THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION OF GREATER LA- WE DO
REPRESENT MOST OF THE MOM AND
POPS IN THE STATE OVER FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS IN TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND MEMBERS. AND WHAT
WE DO RESPECT THAT THE BILL HAS
PREEMPTION IN IT- WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FURTHER
EXTENSION OF THE MORATORIUM.
JUST A COUPLE OF KEY POINTS AS
THE STATE HAS RE OPENED UP IN
THE PANDEMIC IS REGRESSING-
THERE IS NO LONGER A NEED TO
EXTEND EVICTION PROTECTIONS. ANY
FURTHER EXTENSION STATEWIDE
EVICTION MORATORIUM WILL HURT
THE MOM AND POP OWNERS MUCH MORE
THAN THE CORPORATE OWNERS. AND%
THERE ARE NOT BEEN A SIGNIFICANT
IMPOTANT UNLAWFUL DETAINER
EVICTION ACTIONS FILED SINCE THE
LARGER PICTURE WITH MORATORIUM
ENDED LAST YEAR- FOR THOSE
REASONS WE MUST RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION. BUT
MR CHEN MEMBERS PAT MORAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA RENTAL HOUSING
ASSOCIATION WERE OPPOSED TO THE
BILL FOR THAT RASON STATED BY.
THIS BILL THANK YOU. I THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. I'D SAY NINE OPERATOR
WOULD YOU OPEN THE LINES FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
INDICATE OPPOSITION. TO AB ONE
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
AND WITH THIS POINT WE'LL TAKE
NAME ASSOCIATION AND OPPOSITION
. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IN
ENGLAND WITH OPPOSITION CAN
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. TO ENTER
THE COMIC KILL. CURRENTLY NOBODY
QUEUEING UP. I THANK YOU I WILL
THEN. A PRETTY MAY CLOSE LINE SO
WE'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT PUBLISHED A
BOOK. THANK YOU AND IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE MISTER CHAIR
. AND I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS FOR THEIR WORK ON ON
THIS BILL TO EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT- AND I'LL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL BUT I DO
HAVE SOME CONCERNS. ON
LIMITATIONS OF THAT THE BILL HAS
AND PROTECTING TENANTS AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE IS VERY
SALUTARY IN THAT IT PROTECTS
THOSE WHO HAVE SUBMITTED THEIR
RENTAL ASSISTANCE APPLICATION OR
WHO WILL DO SO BY THE END OF THE
MONTH. AND ANYBODY WHO HASN'T
HEARD THIS FROM ME AT. OR FROM
UC UP MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
HERE TODAY IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
IF YOU WANT RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO
GET THAT APPLICATION AND BY THE
END OF THE MONTH THERE'S ONLY A
FEW DAYS LEFT SO I WANT TO
ENCOURAGE. PEOPLE TO DO THAT-
THERE ARE MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND HOUSEHOLDS THAT
ARE STILL WAITING ON PAYMENT-
AND TO- I THINK THAT SPEAKS TO
THE KIND OF SLOWNESS WITH WHICH
THE SAP PROGRAM AS HAS HAS
ROLLED OUT BUT THE- MEASURE
DOESN'T PROTECT THE MILLIONS OF
TENANTS WHO ARE ON THE BRINK OF
RECEIVING AFFECTION NOTICES.
BECAUSE THEY CAN'T MAKE RENT-
AND I DO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
TO A WEEK HAD TO MISS CONNELLY
FROM THE COUNTY OF LA BUT ALSO
SAN FRANCISCO SAN DIEGO RICHMOND
AND FRESNO HAVE ADOPTED EVICTION
PROTECTIONS FOR NON PAYMENT OF
RENT. THAT WOULD HAVE TAKEN
EFFECT ON APRIL FIRST AND THIS
BILL WOULDREVERSE THOSE VOTES
AND TAKE AWAY THE PROTECTIONS-
THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING FOR
THOUSANDS OF TENANTS- OUTSIDE OF
THE ONES WHO WERE HELPING HERE
TODAY. ALSO THE BILL DOES NOT
INCLUDE AN EXTENSION OF THE
APPLICATION FOR RENTAL
ASSISTANCE AND I FEAR THAT THERE
ARE MANY PEOPLE OUT THERE-
BECAUSE OFFOUGHT LANGUAGE
DIFFICULTIES OR OTHER- ISSUES
WILL NOT HAVE SUBMITTED AN
APPLICATION- TENANT ADVOCACY
GROUPS IN FACT HAVE NOTED THAT
THERE'S A SIGNIFICANT NUMBER. OF
NON ENGLISH SPEAKERS WHO HAVE
NOT BEEN ABLE TO ACCESS THE
APPLICATION AND THEREFORE WILL
NOT BE GETTING. RELIEF SINCE THE
START OF THE PANDEMIC SHERIFF'S
DEPARTMENTS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
CARRIED OUT. OF ALREADY AT LEAST
TEN THOUSAND LOCKOUTS AND WHILE
THE MEASURE IN FRONT OF US WILL
HELP. OF MANY TENANTS MY CONCERN
IS THAT WE WILL SEE THOUSANDS
MORE LOCKOUTS AND EVICTION CASES
IF NOTHING MORE IS DONE THEN
THEN THIS BILL SO AGAIN I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHORS. FOR THEIR
HARD WORK ON THIS I KNOW THIS IS
AS FAR AS WE WERE ABLE TO GET A
COMPROMISE I'LL BE SUPPORTING IT
TODAY. AND TO A THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR FOR ALLOWING ME SOME TIME
TO. THE BILL. OTHERS ANYONE ELSE
RIGHT I WOULD LIKE TO. ECHO MY
THANKS TO THE AUTHORS FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD AND I
CERTAINLY SHARE MR BLOOM'S.
FRUSTRATION BUT I THINK. A BILL
THAT WOULD PASS THROUGH THIS
COMMITTEE MAY NOT. THE SOMETHING
THAT WOULD BE QUITE IS
ACCEPTABLE ON THE FLOOR IN THE
OTHER HOUSE AND THROUGH THE REST
OF THE PROCESS I THINK WE DO
NEED. TO BE MINDFUL OF THAT.
WHAT I PREFERRED TO ADDRESS THE
MORATORIUM DIFFERENTLY YES
ABSOLUTELY AND TO PROTECT
EXACTLY THOSE PEOPLE THAT MISTER
BLOOM WAS TALKING ABOUT
ABSOLUTELY. BUT I THINK WE OWE
IT TO THOSE WHO WE CAN HELP. TO
TRY AND MOVE SOMETHING FORWARD I
WILL ADMIT I'M A BIT FRUSTRATED
WITH. SOME OF THE PUSHBACK EVEN
FROM THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
BECAUSE THE THAT SYSTEM HAS NOT
WORKED. THE WAY THAT IT COULD
HAVE WORKED AND THAT IS ONE OF
THE REASONS THAT WE ARE HERE
TODAY WITH WITH THIS EXTENSION
IN THE FORM THAT IT SAID AND I
KNOW EACH OF US IN OUR OFFICES
ARE GETTING A LOT OF CALLS FROM
LANDLORDS AND FROM TENANTS. WHO
ARE BOTH VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
HOW WHAT IS HAPPENING WITH THIS
HOW IT'S ROLLING OUT AND LOOKING
FOR THOSE PROTECTIONS. SO. WITH
THAT MEMBERS YOU MAY CLOSE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS AND THE
COMMON ALSO OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBER- AS WELL AND- IT IS RIGHT
THE OBSERVATION IS RIGHT THIS IS
NOT A PERFECT BILL AND IT IS
FRUSTRATING AT THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE TO FACE AND BEAR THAT
ARE IN PERFECT BUT AS CLOSE AS A
COMPROMISE AS WE CAN GET AS
CLOSE AS WE CAN GET IN
PROTECTIONS- WE GOT THERE AND SO
HERE WE ARE TODAY- WITH THIS
BILL THAT WE DO NOW- WILL HELP
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS. OF
RUNNERS THAT ARE ON THE BRINK OF
EVICTION SO WITH THAT WE MUST
TAKE ACTION AND TO THE CHAIR OF
MY JOINT OTHER MAY ALSO BE ABLE
TO CLOSE THE CASE I WANT TO
THANK MR BLOOM'S COMMENTS I ECHO
SOME OF THOSE AND- SENTIMENTS
AND MISTER CHAIR AS WELL- IN
OTHER PARTS OF THIS BILL I DON'T
LIKE EITHER- AND THINK WE NEED
TO CONTINUE TO DO MORE FOR THOSE
LIVING ON THE BRINK THOSE THAT
ARE WRITTEN BURDENS WHICH
REPRESENTS A SIGNIFICANT PORTION
OF THIS POPULATION PRIOR TO
COVER DURING COVERT AFTER
COVERED- THERE'S A LOT OF POLICY
WORK HAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
TOWARDS THAT END AND HOUSING
WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE
TOWARDS THAT END- FOR A LONG
TIME TO COME. AND SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU ALL-
BUT MY JOIN AUTHOR AND OTHERS ON
THE DICE HERE- TOWARDS THAT BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY THIS
DEADLINE IS COMING UP WE HAVE TO
EXTEND THIS WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WE CAN HELP
RIGHT HERE AND RIGHT NOW- WHICH
IS WHY I'M DOING AUTHORED THIS
BILL NEXT. RESPECT ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. TANK YOU I. LOOKING
FOR A MOTION. AND THE SECOND
SECOND THANK YOU THAT MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED ADDING AN
URGENCY CLAUSE KALRA PLEASE
STONE AYE STONE AYE CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. DAVIES DAVIES I
HOLDEN HOLDEN I KALRA. KALRA AYE
KILEY. MAIENSCHEIN MENTIONED I
REYES REYES AYE BLOOM. AYE BLOOM
AYE BENNETT BENNETT I. THAT BILL
IS OUT IN. OKAY I WILL THE BILLS
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS
THE HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR A FEW
MORE MINUTES WE DO HAVE ONE
MEMBER. WHO THEY DECIDE TO SHOW
UP THANK YOU MR THANK YOU MR.
THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU ALL AND WE ARE
THE GERMANS.